[Music]
Immaculate version today I would have liked to
bring you the thanksgiving of the Ukrainian people
[Applause]
or the Ukrainian for the peace that
we have been asking the Lord for a long time
instead
I still have to present to you the plea of ​​the
children
of the elders of the fathers and mothers
of the young  of that tormented land
that suffers so much
but in reality
We all know
that you are with them and with all the
suffering as if you were next to the Cross of
your son
Thank you our mother
looking at you
who are without sin we can
continue to believe and hope
that on  may hate win love over
lies may truth win
over celebration may forgiveness win over
war may
peace win
so be it
[Applause]